morning guys
uh so we're doing i think this is our
third workout with sensei hind
um we're gonna hit legs a little harder
today we're at the regular
seven seven um then we'll do about a six
minute meditation here at the end
so let's do our stretching and warm up
here
okay a little more than shoulder width
certainly the legs warming up the body
let that force generated by the legs
transmit up the body
and out the hands this is nami ryoku
weight force
good to go front and back
you do this the way i do this is relax
the arms
as much as you can let the body weight
sink back and forth
take all that in the legs and let the
legs generate all the force
get outside
good come back to center big breath in
reaching up
and back
forward down
hey
coming back up arms out
come behind the back interlock fingers
big breath in
forward and down
circle the upper body
the other direction
and back up release the hands
coming to one side
other side
back over to up on all these trying to
leave your back heel downs you want your
back heel on the ground
if you you can't but that's the goal now
the other side
go up
and coming to center right middle of
what's on the knees back
forward
hands in the middle for the feet
and sitting back good nice big breath in
turning down
back center big breath in turning down
back to center feet together nice
straight back deep breath in
forward down to arrange your spine too
much
bring the feet in nice straight back
dropping the chest down
and coming onto the stomach
hands under the shoulders big breath in
coming up
remember the stretch shouldn't be in
your back it should be in your core
and down
get me up one more time
keep your butt or feet on the ground
sitting back
hands on the ground stretch your upper
back
and rolling up
hand in front of the face we try to grab
the base of the thumb twist the thumb
towards me
sink the hand down clip the gauge
and other side palm towards the face
you're trying to grab the base of the
thumb
thumb towards me sink it down
and elbow up palm away are you trying to
grab the base of the index finger
turn the thumb towards me push the hand
to the side some kill
and other side elbow up palm away we're
trying to grab the base of the index
finger
thumb towards me arm to the side
third principle
making a ring with the index finger and
the thumb put that ring flat on the palm
of your hand
push your uh arm back you're like your
wrist is coming back
my fingers are pointing forward and so
are my elbows with my elbow
this is knee kill
the other side ring palm of the hand
pull the hands back hold the fingers and
the elbows point forward
knee kill feel stretch all through the
side of your forearm
good pulling the fingers back yakugokyo
and other side yakugokyo
shaking out the wrists
arms
arm across the shoulder across the chest
pull it in flat
other side
arm behind the head you're doing this
really trying to look up
so i'm using the neck muscles to help
stretch that arm out straight
and the other side and there's a warm-up
got just about through a whole warm up
today
all right good okay so we're gonna come
out here
at center we're going to start really
simply so just like the warm-up
i'm going to drop to one side stretch
i'm going to immediately go to the other
side
stretch and working those legs i'm doing
this
if you can't go this deep that's fine
don't go this deep
so if you need to get here that's fine
we're going back and forth
pause in between just a short pause
other side
short pause short pause
short pause
all the pause is doing is taking out the
momentum so you're not just kind of
springing up and down
like this don't do this kind of get to
the side
short pause push up short pause
push up good okay so coming into
set up as flat as you can be
up on the balls of your feet here rock
up
balance slow push up
the heels come down as they naturally
will
and now we're all the way up and down
nice and slow
still not all the way down let the heels
come up a little bit
and now we're all the way down control
the knees down
and flat balls of heat
balance up
still not all the way up
and now we're up and down
nice slow descent
slow slow slow it's coming all the way
down
and all the way down good control bring
those knees down
and flat good job all right go to a
regular
uh up so close the feet knees up
stand up good down regular speed
knees down flat
feet knees up up
down knees down
flat feet
knees up down
knees deep
deep knees up
down knees
feet feet
knees up ahead good check out the legs
good okay we're going to come into a
forward lean
nice forward lean position we're not
going to do a lot of push-ups today just
a few
okay all the way down all the way up
i mean all the way down your your
stomach and your head should touch
all the way down all the way up
you can't do this modify by dropping
your knees
all the way down all the way up
so if you're having a hard time doing
this here all the way down
all the way up
one more all the way down all the way up
good halfway down up halfway down
up halfway down up halfway down
up halfway down up all the way down rest
so i'm resting completely on the ground
and up
all the way down rest
all the way up looks like cameras
okay sorry camera froze the middleware
push up got three more
all the way down rest
all the way up
all the way up good on your back
egg beaters
other direction so my feet are just
moving around circles
bicycle
the direction
eat together feet up
down sit up
down feet up down
sit up down feet up
down sit up
down feet up down
sit up down
feet up crunches go
good job standing back up
squeezing it all right arms out tight
circle forward
tight circles back
tight circles forward
hold the arms out
okay keep those arms out when i'm done
take circles forward
take circles back pause
palms up
keep those palms up slightly down
keep those palms up straight up as they
can be
slightly down palms staying up
slightly down keep those palms up
slide down push them in all the way to
the side as far as you can with a little
penguin with your hands
backwards and rest
good all right guys not too bad okay
we're gonna do a
six minute meditation here when the bell
goes off or when the
alarm goes off ignore it you listen for
the bell so
three and three out observational
meditation so remember the idea is
to stay here in the moment so don't
track
thoughts down don't conjure up what
you're going to have for breakfast or
how your day zoom is going to be so
don't worry about that stuff just stay
in the moment
if you find yourself drifting then just
bring yourself back to the present
and don't give yourself a bad time about
it right so don't say oh i'm a bad boy
right because it doesn't matter it's
just more bad meditation if you're doing
that
all right here we go three and three out
[Music]
okay guys that's the end of our
meditation um
i want to say something about meditation
real quick if you want
meditation to be some mystical thing
sweet
um but i would turn the video off right
now i'm gonna talk a little bit about
the mundane
practical truth of meditation so i think
when people
see someone meditating they're like oh
that's awesome
mystic guy stuff and it is mystic guy
stuff
but it has a really important function
so just like the calisthenics for our
body the meditation
clears out our mind straightens and
strengthens our mind so
when you're meditating you are training
yourself
no different than lifting weights or
doing calisthenics or anything else so
at the end of this we're not meditating
because it's mystical and sweet we're
meditating because
it trains our mind in aikido our mind
being strong
is super important at least is important
probably more
much more important than our body being
strong the reason for that is because
in aikido we're talking about always
dealing with people who are bigger and
stronger than us and aikido the other
guys always stronger than me i have no
ability to physically compete with that
person or person
so because of that my mind has to be
sharp and i have to be able to call upon
my mind
to act the way i need it to act when i
need it to act that way right and so
that means having you know all different
uh four of the
the kokoro ideas right so mooshin
furoshin zanshin shoshin
so i can call upon those instantly
whenever i want and meditation is a way
to start training your mind to do that
and there's lots of different kinds of
meditation
i use observational meditation almost
exclusively for myself
i do do a few other meditations and and
before this series is done we'll
probably get into a few other
meditations but
meditation is there purposefully to
build the mind just like calisthenics
are there purposefully to build the body
so
you have to look at this as a mental
exercise in some ways the five-minute
meditation to me is harder
than a longer meditation because i have
to instantly get where i want to get
right
and if i don't instantly get there then
i tend to tell myself like oh you're
doing bad
and then that's more that i
don't want right so whereas a 30 minute
meditation i can just kind of like ease
into it and then
before long i'm in the space and
everything's cool but in a five minute
meditation
there's more pressure on me a lot of
times to get to where i need to be
and this should be if i could let go of
that pressure i would be better at
meditating
but that's the catch 22 of the whole
thing so uh the meditation
is is is awesome and fun and relaxing i
guess it can be
um but to me it's it's mentally taxing
it's the same as when i tax my body and
i feel about the same mentally fatigued
as i do
physically fatigued after that exercise
okay guys so we'll see you
next tuesday right around 7 a.m have a
wonderful day talk to you later